James is in Houston
hi James welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave how's it going better than I
deserve what's up so I am currently on
paid suspension from my job I've worked
in I've been working there about three
years I got into an argument with one of
my superiors I use a word I was a
wouldn't have used so that's really the
reason while I'm on suspension there had
been things going on before that
happened that led up to that that I've
been keeping to myself basically I just
I don't respect the people who I work
for but it's a really good job and I
like to work so I just wanted your
opinion on whether I should go back
there or if they even let me back or try
to find a new place to work my family's
been telling me that you know you know
bosses your whole life so you don't like
so just gotta go through it how old are
you 24 okay no you should not go back
there but most importantly is not those
people or what's wrong with them most
importantly is the man in your mirror
he's going to have a lot more to say
about your future success than some guy
who is or isn't a jerk at the ball at
the workplace what were you making about
45 okay doing what it's in a industrial
bakery okay
well I mean you're not afraid of work
but you've got to learn to control the
guy in your mirror in his mouth because
he gets you in trouble right right and
that's all of us have gone through that
growing up and sometimes we grow up at
24 sometimes we grow up at 54
sometimes it's 14 but most the time it's
later than that I think you got to say
what was my part in this let's pretend
that everybody over there's a jerk
incompetent and doesn't deserve your
respect okay
let's just pretend that for a second how
you react to that says more about you
does them that makes sense right
yeah that's my concern if I'm you you
got to work on that part and that means
getting in a good church with maybe a
guys group getting a good Bible study
and learning to control your temper
because that's what controls your tongue
I've dealt with that myself as a younger
man so I can relate